e
okay I'm going to go ahead and start the
uh subcommittee review of the education
rules those part of the education rules
that we're tasked with that are going to
be going before the state part on April
11 and so this is not a subcommittee
which is reviewing all 306 rules that's
not what we're doing this is a
subcommittee that's put put together by
the speaker for us to to look at any
rules which are coming up by way of the
department that may impact policy or we
for us to make recommendations to jel
car the rules which we're dealing with
today in accordance with what we've
received from the Board of
Education are
.49 those are the components within the
Ed minimum stand or public school
approval which are looking at curricular
areas and those elements within that
we're not looking at the all the
business that's prior to that dealing
with number of
courses rules for uh classrooms or or or
uh definitions which are on the first
page and what is our graduation
competency what's not that um that is a
later time uh so what we're going to do
is look at the and we're going to look
at the information which we got directly
from the Department which is put out by
Julia Shay uh on behalf of the
administrative rule she's the uh rules
coordinator over at
doe if anybody needs a copy of what I
have here we have some extra copies if
you'd like to you know come up and get
what we're going to be looking at I have
another see I think representa Tanner
and there's four people that are on this
subcommittee it's representative Cornell
represent luno represent cordelli and
myself these appointments have been made
by the speaker's office uh there is
yours right there let's see you
have goes are your thank you yeah and
then they would get one of each of
these
right
okay okay so that would be that and then
uh here's another one of these right
here okay oh we did he uh represent Hall
we got to make sure that um Bor excuse
me uh that Len Tanner gets
one did you get yours represent
Tanner there there's there's two copies
two things one the order of events which
they will be taking up by way of the
State Board board and to the the rules
items so M Mr chair yes yeah um thanks
before we um go into the review and
discussion on the proposed rule changes
I was wondering if you could
um just remind us all what the um what
the process of what the I guess the the
um responsibility of this um rules
Review Committee is and um and also the
responsibility of the um accountability
and over the statutory um committee on
education accountability and oversight
and its responsibilities with respect to
proposed rule changes uh prior to uh
these changes being considered by JL car
yeah yeah uh what we have before us
today are the minimum academic standards
for public school approval and you know
the legislative oversight committee for
improvement and
assessment has responsibility for
reviewing the academic
standards we have we passed legislation
out of this committee earlier this year
where we were looking to also have
statutory Authority through that
committee which would be the oversight
committee to also review the minimum
standards for public school approval now
in accordance with
193e
2A um we have a section there which
deals with curriculum where the general
court every 10 years must look at what
we're doing in terms of those criteria
substantive criteria for an adequate
education which are in in the rules in
the sections we're going to be looking
at today this is why we're we're looking
at this today simply because this is not
a statutory or standing committee that's
been you know in the the uh you'll see
on the web this is a a committee that's
been put together by leadership to
ensure that we can give some support to
Jael car when they review the rules
after they've been you know heard by the
state board and they come to jel car for
their look and jel car has not had I
would say not the expertise but they
haven't had the time really to deal with
the wide variety of departments and
bureaus where these rules come from
everything from Health and Human
Services to criminal justice to the
whole Transportation the whole nine
yards and so they've asked now that
these subcommittees which are within the
policy areas look at potential rules
which are being looked at by the state
board and which will come to jelar and
give our thoughts in terms do the
proposed changes mesh with statutory law
and policy that we are familiar with so
that is our task
today and I know that there's going to
be issues today when we're dealing with
we're looking at the word competency
throughout this section we also have
competencies defined in the section that
we're not going to be dealing with today
the first part when you see the
definitions of that and that's been one
of the big big concerns dealing with the
one of them with the
306s we will be as a education committee
having a another meeting yet to be
scheduled where we will be looking at
the entire gamut of
306 before those rules go to gelar and
they have you know just this what past
week were presented to the state
board so now that that's occurred we
will have folks that were involved in
the writing of them in fact I even spoke
with one person yesterday that
represents the business industry
associating at the at the uh advisory
coun for Career Technical education was
explaining some of the things which went
on with
306 so what I'd like to do right now
does that explain where I I I I think
that that does a lot of it Mr chair um
the the one other the the one other
thing i' i' I'd ask that you um you
mentioned though and you you just sort
of um touched on it is uh the action
that the State Board um may have taken
last week with respect to the proposed
rules uh I don't know if that
constituted um uh the State Board
approving the academic the changes to
the academic
standard I I wasn't there I didn't
participate in that that was a that was
a hearing I don't think there now I'm
just surmising I don't believe that they
actually made a approved those a vote
okay there was no vote taken okay um and
these this portion of the package comes
up and yes you'll note on the to the uh
second
page well the second piece of paper it's
actually page three where you see the
information that's provided by the
administrative rules coordin
the deadline for submission of materials
and writing if practicable for the
agency in the electronic format would be
April 30th public hearing is scheduled
for April 11 2024 at 1:00 over at
Granite State College V Event Center so
we're actually looking at this component
right here prior to that and if we have
recommendations I will certainly share
those recommendations with the
department and also with Jael card okay
and then and then finally on on you know
as we're sort of laying out a a a
timeline of of um of U for lack of a a
better word of uh state or bureaucratic
administrative actions towards towards
these rules uh 193
e2a Roman 4 C says the State Board shall
not amend any existing academic
standards so now we're talking academic
standards and shall not approve any new
AC mic standards without the prior
review and recommendation of the
legislative oversight committee
established in 193 C8 uh C call 8A which
is the oversight committee you were just
referencing that you chair that's been
the issue that we have had we're
contesting that we have that authority
to review these in accordance this
component right here in accordance with
1932a and the Roman numeral you're
speaking to there right prior to state
board action on that's what we're doing
right now through this well that that's
not what we're doing cuz we're not this
isn't the this isn't the the 198
CA committee that's right this is this
is another committee so we're going to
take it step by step it's the same
people but or many of the same people
the the the C the the ca committee also
includes uh members of the Senate right
yeah yeah but do you notice the date on
this April that's when they're hearing
it that's not where they're taking
action right but and so that's later on
you know where they have the electronics
can be you know information can be
submitted up to April 30th sure so then
they have to schedule this now they're
on a time frame similar for this portion
as they are for all 306 but but just and
it's going to go through to almost like
July okay just my my point is is that
the the
C legislative oversight committee will
will have to vote and make a
recommendation prior to state board
acting on um on these standards when we
when we put that in the calendar we're
we're going to be going with the full
package of 306 at the same time that's
when we will also you know be making
recommendations to that oversight
committee where then that committee will
meet and go forward okay thank you
yeah okay so let's start right at the
top of this with the first uh uh bullet
there with the
30631 regarding the Arts education is
being re reopt with the amendment and
replaces the word program with
curriculum and amends the language so
the school board is providing a
curriculum that is consistent with the
comp with competencies in earlier
sections of Ed
306 a lot of this language is going to
be repetitive as we go
through so looking at that you also have
a copy of the rules and I've been
informed that the the rules which we're
addressing are not those which were
proposed yesterday or the last week in
this section area they're not supposedly
section so so so so Mr chair you're
you're you're right going through these
first
um the first page there's a lot program
replaced in second page a lot of program
replaced with curriculum um I
guess what does that why why did they do
that and what does it mean I don't work
for the state board well is there well
is there somebody um from the Department
that could address that I I if you look
at the website for the Department I'm
going to try to bring that up right the
State Board of
Education you can also see when this is
posted here there also reference say the
introduced I don't know what that means
okay the rules as introduced the initial
proposal okay right here okay the one
that I I provided you yeah yeah we've
got that yeah febru the February 15 24
right um so that's what we've got to but
I it would still be good to know what
what you know if the if the moving Parts
here are essentially
uh program being replaced with
curriculum you know why did they do it
mean I mean if it's a if it's a if it's
a change that doesn't make a change then
why do they make the
change I think that there must be some
sort of um intent and meaning for the
change
that could be a question we put down as
changing the the issue dealing with
program and curriculum replacing program
with
curriculum does that is that contrary to
anything we have in
statute that's a good good question
that's the question that we have to ask
mhm because if it doesn't conflict with
statute then a recommendation would be
the Jael card we don't have a problem
right right so so so we we need to be
also referencing our our our statutes
and so it's the outcome of this meeting
going to be since there's nobody from
the Department
here
right so right so is the is the outcome
of this meeting going to be
that they are here there's a slug of
them downstairs right now testifying on
to the Senate Ed okay but they're not
here in this meeting so yeah um uh uh so
is the is the outcome going to be
questions that we put into a memo that
goes to the department that our ad hoc
rules committee is going to one of the
questions I do have Dave is represent
luno that's okay is that we reference
the word competencies throughout these
changes here but but the definition of
competencies early in 306 is not in
accordance with
statute
okay and if you look at the statutory
definition and then you look at the
definition that's going to be in Ed 306
they're
different and that's something that as a
subcommittee working for Jael card right
now or submitting to Jael car we should
note
that there should be a statutory
reference for everything we're
doing so so are Mr chair are we going to
prepare a report following this meeting
that will go to doe for answers and also
go to JL
car the the way that our task has been
we we are responsible for submitting
directly to Jael car to the chair of
that committee with concerns which we
have I I I'm assuming they could be cced
also to the Department
for them to you know if we we have those
concerns yes how's that report going to
be prepared oh it have to come out of
here I'd have to write it with all the
changes which we're going to note today
okay
yeah so let's start working on it
okay okay I want to open up my computer
so I can reference the where we are in
terms
of
so Mr chair yeah this short two-page
thing is a summary of this bigger thing
that we yes supposed to explain what's
being done on each area thank you so we
want to look at first at that first area
there
83631 and then looking at what we have
here
so I guess the question what's the
program so I think that's a that's a a
question also when you look looking at
looking at the whole sentence the local
school board shall used to be require
that an
arts program an Arts educ ation program
for grades 1 through
12 um
provides and so now
removed the local school board shall
curriculum and the and the summary
says may be included so it may be incl
included but it doesn't have to be
included so they can just leave it out
if they want to yeah and does does
curriculum include instruction because
program sounds like it would include
instruction they're separate all right
so so maybe one definition here is that
program is curriculum plus
instruction and that's being so the
instruction part is being is being um
jettisoned as you recall when we we
passed legislation early this year with
the curriculum
Frameworks the curriculum Frameworks
serve as a
guide we also Incorporated in the
language of that bill that curriculum
Frameworks also reflect the academic
standards right but the Frameworks are
something that comes from the Department
of Education from the state board to
from the state board to assist school
districts in in in developing their
their curriculum the locals are
responsible for curriculum uh and
instruction so the state board's not
responsible for instruction but these
are the minimum uh standards for for
public school approval and and schools
provide both curriculum and instruction
and it seems like the approval standards
now are eliminating the instruction part
and just going with the curriculum part
and that that leaves um I I don't know
where the I don't know how the
instruction happens and I don't know how
the where the learning happens if um if
all you're leaving the schools with is
the set of encyclop this is part of the
conflict which we have and we've dealt
with this over the
years yes these local school districts
have Authority for
instruction the scope and the sequence
of when they teach these skills
representative Cornell School might want
to teach something in the ninth grade
represent lunos might do it in the 10th
grade that's part of the sequence of how
but then when we align those with an
assessment tool the assessment tool is
identified in conjunction of being
teachers have to review it um that's
within the law as well a number of folks
have to review it but that's given at a
certain grade level for all schools so
that's been the conflict I've always had
is that that's that Statewide assessment
may not always be assessing what has
been
taught at a particular grade level and
maybe the following year the next year
that the kids so the kids are now
proficient in grade 10 rather than
taking something in the previous grade
level or any grade I just pick a grade
grade 11 but but Mr chair I mean I think
you're introducing Statewide assessment
at so let see so instruction though is
separate from curriculum no I understand
that but but going back to the word
that's been removed from This Is The
Word program and and just a few moments
ago I was sort of you know um
considering that well program is
curriculum plus instruction but you just
introduced another important term
assessment so program is program
curriculum plus instruction plus
assessment that would sort of compromise
a that that would comprise a
program and so are we are we now leaving
instruction and assessment out of the
approval just it's a question
yeah and I know we're using 30631 but I
it I think it almost applies to
everything that's on the summary sheet
here oh exactly exactly this is this is
the
issue
and curriculum has always been a local
control
issue you establish whether you're going
to if you're looking at a textbook
whether you're going to use H hotton
Mifflin or silver bdad or some other
manufacturer that most of them mcra
Hill that's your business as a school
district the academic standards are what
you have to teach that is what has to
remain
constant I I I get that
but what what's being what's
being proposed here as a change is
replacing the word I mean in addition to
other things is replacing the word
program with the word curriculum so so
if if and I don't know if this is true
um if if program is curriculum plus
instruction plus
assessment pass out to you the final
proposed draft
of the whole nine yards and we can look
at the definitions here yeah and see
that's so where do we find the def well
it be right on the first or second page
curriculums at the
base and see they referencing curriculum
meaning as defined in 193 e2a Romans
6 item C I have more copies of those if
folks would like to have those the
e2a 6C I'm right here on
it curriculum means the lessons in
academic content taught in school or in
a specific course or program so
program curriculum means the lessons in
academic content taught so taught is
instruction
right in school or in a specific course
of
program so that would sort of be
consistent with how we parsed out what
um what program means that program
includes curriculum
plus instruction instruction right and
if you look at assessment too right if
you if you look at uh 30614 the current
um rules which is uh basic instru Inu
standards the local school board shall
require that each school has an
instructional program which includes
policies on homework promoting students
Etc it doesn't get into content yeah
curriculum where in 30614 were you
looking
um X out stuff the line no um I'm sorry
it's uh I'm looking at the current one I
don't know you're looking looking what
just handed out yeah yeah where which
page are you on
Glenn on the current of the current yeah
um on on the or final proposal on page
nine that's what I'm looking
yeah you go
back yeah basically it's what's crossed
out on page nine of the final proposal
draft uh 30614 based constructional
standards um local schoolb should
require that each school has an
instructional program which
includes um the various policies listed
under
that L alphabet soup here the
instructional standards that we tried to
eliminate all the references to stand
standards to academic
standards we have instruction
period and you look at the definition of
instruction which is on the front page
or in the second
page means deliberate and strategic
learning so
so M Mr chair I'm not a you know I've
never been a teacher um but instruction
doesn't stand on its own curriculum I
mean in let me say it another way
um it it seems to me that that that a
program would you know a program
in calculus let's say would include a
curriculum would include instruction and
it would include assessment
correct and and you know you could
almost replace the the word program with
course or class well for example like
CTE a
program as a program of studies leading
to that certification in the skill area
that we want as the outcome is so you
may have three or four or five different
courses that are part of that
woodworking program
yeah if if you look at I'm looking at
the initial proposal page four for CT
e
um in B1 this is Page four um based
on program is crossed out and has
changed to curriculum specific
competencies which all fall under the
CTE program where you looking page four
page four of the initial proposal not
the not the Revis not the Rev okay we're
all going the wrong way here
all right the initial proposal from
February 15 so now this is very
interesting now this is really really
showing where the word program is
getting replaced with the word
curriculum right because curriculum and
competencies go hand inand right no C
curriculum is curriculum competency
competency is assessment is part of
assessment okay compeny is a where you
have
the that bar
to ascertain whether student has met the
academic standards that's assessment
right so then under B there it says An
approved CT program shall be one that
and number
one um it replaces makes it based on
curriculum competencies okay there's
competencies there's program and then
down in um four implements third party
assessments Okay so all right so you've
got under program you've got curriculum
competencies and
assessments
um right to say we're all talking about
programs implication of cric instruction
assessment and competencies but program
if we're using the final draft is is the
is the bible program is not Define is
it's the definition we're making I'm on
page two Rick the final this not
there we're we're guessing what they
mean by program but we don't have to
guess what what's what's being changed
here
um curriculum specific
competencies could be um um you know
pick the pick the the this in in this
particular section the the CTE class so
so whether it's um a um a culinary arts
uh class being able to demonstrate that
that
you've you know how to perform something
um in a to meet a competency um in in uh
in that in that curricular area so in
that case we're not you're not even
talking about curriculum you're not
talking about instruction you're only
talking about assessment uh in that in
in item one B1 under
30633 based on curricular specific
says where are you
allly where on page one under 30602 on
definition and the
compy that just saying we be able to
apply
that's
yeah applying is a form of assessment
that's what this is saying poliy
according to this new definition policy
isine a specific set
of that's a performance assessment right
so that's an authentic performance
assessment that's that is so so to to
your to your point represent m
curriculum is there's the curriculum
okay it's just it's it's just a bunch of
bunch it's a
thing um instruction is now we're going
to what do you think we're going to read
through this we're going to talk about
it we're going to learn about it we're
going to really understand it that's the
instruction part right so so it's not
just here you go here you go there's the
curriculum and then the and then the
assessment is is the okay how well do
these students
understand the curriculum and how can
thatu could could I ask Mr chair
representative Tanner join
us well she I mean she's not on the
committee she's not on it she can sit at
the table this is a discussion so but
but you know the there's three
components that we got to have
align curriculum instruction and
assessment totally agree and that's been
years and have someone from the
Department who wrote who did this she's
really not she's not no there's nobody
else there's no one from instruction
down there no no but could Linda could
represent
Tanner chair but she's not going to be
part of the sub like you
know Steve's not a member of the he's
sitting here with us and so she could
they could sit right here if they want
to fact that's been offered to him yeah
yeah I I think maybe program isn't
defined because they've taken it out and
they're not using it so there is no
definition of program because in the new
rules they're not using program so they
gone where's the definition of
curriculum
book what a student should be able to
know and do and it is an
assessment
[Music]
E28 that's how
compen it
ISS so that all you have to do is if you
can if you can tie a knot then it says
that you've had instruction in you know
different kinds
of we we really don't have standards for
instruction that's a local
issue as you we we have curriculum
defined here we have
um academics defined in your law books
560 but instruction is something you can
go to a classroom you see different
forms of instruction just about any
class you go into I I I I understand
that but but I guess by removing
instruction from this does that mean
that that public schools don't have to
provide instruction is instruction being
removed well the word program is being
replaced by curriculum and and again I'm
going back to my theory here that
program is it as it's used in a must
provide a program um
that that that it's a combination of
it's curriculum plus instruction plus
assessment and if we're replacing
program with then curriculum with with
the word curriculum then we're leaving
out instruction and assessment
instruction is on the next page but it's
it's on the second page sorry you have
instruction instructional time that's
time on task stuff that we've all as
teachers been familiar with you know
engage time vers seat time instruction
means deliberate and strategic
approaches it
this active prac teach that's what's
crossed out
this this just says facilitate student
learning so you could say go read pages
10 through 12 15 and you're facilitating
their learning because you're telling
them what to do but you're not teaching
them anything yeah so it's not teach so
teaching but you're facilitating student
learning isn't that teaching no it's
it's of teaching it's
not you can lead a horse to water but
you can't make him drink kind of thing
you know but some people can get them to
with the
teaching yeah so te so would you say
that teaching includes content expertise
pedagogy and
facilitating and and maybe other things
too I don't and instru and instructing
yeah teaching and yeah that's why it was
yeah just
mention we do mention pedagogy in
Statute in
places but we don't Define it I I'm I'm
honestly Mr chair I'm blown Away by the
the degree of change being proposed here
that that this isn't just sort of um
administrative cleanup or or um
housekeeping clarifying rules this is a
absolute turn um Public Schools turn
teaching upside down and I I I don't
agree with you totally on that we've had
competencies built into our
instructional processes for years yeah
I'm I'm I'm not I'm not criticizing that
so we're looking at a competency based
educational program so in as I was
trying to explain to Dave in a comp at
least when I was doing it the Competency
Based consisted of
rubrics consisted of rubrics that that
the teacher developed from the
curriculum and also from assessment that
were no no no no it it didn't come come
from curriculum curriculum is what you
use to for your instruction it's that
it's like he just explained curriculum
is that book right there but we designed
the the the
standards in which we're going to
purchase that book if that book doesn't
mesh up with our standards not going to
you're not going to buy it you're going
to get a curriculum that does reflect
your standards and your standards are
then are what we base competencies off
of
and what I'm saying is in the CL in the
classroom though what happens is the
teacher builds rubrics which are
specific knowledge points and skill
points skill sets that lead the student
to an overall competency and then the
competency is bringing all those
knowledges and skills together in a
project that demonstrates or some sort
of essay or something that demonstrates
that they can use the knowledge the
specific knowledges and skills Within
that curriculum um and so to to not have
any of
that notice I guess is saying that okay
if a if a student says they can read a
ruler and they
can then they can do fractions you know
um and they haven't had any instruction
competency go back to the rsas
right under um
e2a it it says Roman 5A the curriculum
shall present educational goals broad
pedological approaches and strategies
for assistant St assisting students in
the development of skills competencies
and knowledge called for by the minimum
standards um it then goes on to Define
academic standards mean what a student
should know and be able to do in a
course at each grade level M then
curriculum means lessons and academic
content taught in a school or in a
specific
course um and the final draft and their
definition of curriculum points directly
rsas and just like is indicated in here
competencies mean a grouping of related
academic
standards a student should be able to
apply apply there's that word as a
opportunities I think that paragraph's
probably the Crux of all this stuff
right here right right I I I I think
that's important but but um but just
sort of stepping back aren't the
individual comp aren't the components
assessment I mean I'm not I'm not a
teacher so I don't I I know there's
subcomponents
and things and skills and uh but but at
at its at its most fundamental layer
you've got three things you've got the
curriculum you've got
instruction and then you've got
assessing the what the kids have what
yeah are they are they comp have they
mastered their
competencies and and I know there's you
know from my time on the board you've
got the the you know formative and
summative assessments but I think that's
more that's more practicum than it is
than it is um the the the sort of the
fundamental the fundamental thing in in
assessment and at at the local level and
standards at the state level absolutely
and and and again I'm getting back to if
if what they what the current rules
means in using the word program are
those the combination of those three
things curriculum instruction assessment
replacing the word program with just one
of those terms leaves the other two out
and and I'm wondering is that the intent
of um of these rule changes that that
the state is now
uh shifting its focus away from
education to just um
content curriculum I don't get that
well because they're replacing the word
program with
curriculum but if we go back to the
initial proposal the first one we're
were looking at
30631 everything that's described there
is more curriculum
rather than a program the you know you
could say that there should be a program
on Arts education but here the rules are
really defining What's
um components that should be in um the
Arts education for instance um we've
talked about Arts really includes dance
music theater
Etc and that's spelled out here so
that's part of the curriculum but it
still says which may include right it so
it may not include so all these things
that yes they are
important but they may be included and
they cross out provides and and write in
include right at the top yep so when you
when you use may include um is is that
essentially saying you can these are
just examples but you don't have to do
any of this and it's not really even a
rule if it's a May right when you change
provide or is this being considered
I was just looking for the word program
in
often well I I
I I haven't been able to find the
definition of program either and it but
it's currently used in statute so I
would I would I would put it out there
what is the intent of you the use of the
word program
and um I I
I I think it's got a meaning that
um that
includes I think it's got a more
comprehensive meaning I think it's more
curriculum I think it includes
instruction and
assessment well according there there
what they have here in in that paragraph
that in
1932a
five is saying that curriculum includes
pedagogy where where what P what page
are you on
560 curriculum shall present let's see
jump here curriculum shall present
education goals broad pedagogical
approaches now years ago I'll date
myself there was concern that schools
weren't teaching science
properly so they came up with programs
like ESS which were inquiry oriented
science you get a box of
materials and then the students were
able to inquire and build and project
and apply so that was also the
curriculum another one was
skiss and so at that point in time the
program
included these components and and the
assessment component was being able to
do m not not a test it was being able to
do perform yeah yeah and that's dating
right back to the
1970s that's an elementary school right
ESS gu programs inquiry or science and
put out by the National Science
Foundation and and Department of
Education was really pushing it too when
it became a department in a federal
level so at that point in time the
program included all that MH right
that's what that's sort of what I've
been saying and so I'm not understanding
why we're taking a terminology out of
here and
just and then writing a definition for
program which shall include or be part
you know your program is going to have
to have all those three basic
components to ensure it's being taught
yeah leave program in and provide a
definition for program
yeah and some many explain that one to
me why it's not there yeah all right so
I I think that might sort of sum up what
we're trying to deal with here today
because we can go around and around and
this it's like education noted for the
alphabet soup and and and I I agree with
you Mr chair I think Roman 5 on page 560
has a lot of the alphabet soup in
there where it talks about curriculum
including pedagogy I mean is that
okay yeah it talks about goals the whole
nine
knowledge Mr chair I know I'm not on the
committee but I'm getting I just I'm
listening to the luno uh description of
program being CIA when you look at um on
on five three on 160 when it talks about
curriculum it says or specific course or
program those are two separate things
I'm on the bottom page of 560 the RSA
193 932a it's on the five that Dave was
just talking about when they Define
curriculum lessons and academic content
taught in a school or in a specific
course or program so that's not the
program is not the same as the one we
were just using as the CIA as the
oversight of Education critical
instruction assess
that's the three different things you
program and I know I'm not on the
committee I'm just saying that that last
sentence in Roman five on that same
page I think tries to addresses what I
was trying to say at the very beginning
it's up to the Local District the local
teachers the local school board the
local administrators decide what our
instructions going to look
like what the scope in sequence of
presentation of the
curriculum is going to look like and it
says it all right here it says it is
respons local teachers administrators
and school boards to identify and
Implement approaches best suited for
students in their communities to acquire
the skills and knowledge included in the
curriculum to determine the scope
organization and sequence of course
offerings and to choose the methods of
instruction that the activities and the
materials to be
used that that's an excellent part of
that that's a good part of that
paragraph I think the proceeding
language in that paragraph is a little
bit you know well it's just a
conglomeration of everything but down
here it says specifically and if you go
back to the beginning of 193 e it says
it's a shared responsibility however
responsibility now through rule making
are we now starting to shift curriculum
state by putting it in
question because we've always had
curricular Frameworks which are
guidelines right we've never said this
is your curriculum we don't have a state
curriculum here we're not New York
State we li allow flexibility you pick
the curriculum to teach the required
academic
standards and see the competencies is
that assessment and the question we've
been raising as a policy committee I
have been for years is that how do we
know that our Statewide assessment is
actually assessing properly what we
teach
in reading and language arts probably
so but maybe not in other areas that's
why we don't have a state assessment in
so social
studies and science we have yes we have
stuff so what is it that we need to find
out here Mr
chair well I think we because as I when
we start out here there's some things
that are going to reference back into
the rules as being
proposed
competencies and curriculum and taking
out program which are now impacting the
area that we're responsible for
here so we can say this looks good but
upfront so I guess that is the concern I
have is that why why the need to change
curriculum versus
teacher in definition of instruction but
that see that's not our charge here but
it will be down the way here I don't
like it when they change provides to may
include or sh to May CU where are you
right now well um right at the first
paragraph of page one of on the initial
proposal the initial
proposal okay where it changes
curriculum from program and then which
provides and I and I think well this is
a new one but reading the old one there
maze
but if we're making the change to per to
curriculum right that goes back to
also yeah yeah but I mean so local
responsibility is a
responsibility issue um minimum
standards is a here's what what what
each local school board is responsible
to at least do it sets a it sets a a
hard deck as to um uh What uh what what
every school board is responsible
for and when we when we change that from
a from a required um you know
shall require
that an Arts education program so I'm
reading from the you know the crossed
out stuff um in grades 1 through
12 provides and it lists all those
things so now it's saying that
um that it no longer has to include
these
things well it says may include right
for example like technology in the art
art
program you don't have to have it but
you're required to have a Arts
program Arts
curriculum it says right up top the
local school board shall provide an Arts
education curriculum shall right now the
things that you choose to within that
program is something that's your choice
that so we're going from a a a program
that
that was required to provide these I'm
just looking at the very first but I
think it's the same conversation
everyone these first
seven
areas no longer requiring them school
boards to do those seven areas as a
minimum standard but these are examples
of things you could
do is that is that how that's being
read I think it comes down to our having
to really get a good handle on what is
program yeah program is that big
umbrella and then underneath that
umbrella you have those three components
we talked about curriculum instruction
assessment and there that is the that's
where the latitude is you don't have any
latitude as far as providing a program
you shall provide
art within that then you're going
to within curriculum instruction and
assessment provide those things but
you're going to also you must address
the academic standards associated with
art and that's why we're trying to get a
definition somewhere or not
definition we want to see the academic
standards I asked a question I've asked
the committee in the public here before
show me the academic standards and the
answer is the Frameworks M but we don't
have Frameworks that's out of law right
now so so we really can't really point
to academic
standards that the state board has
approved those by way the Frameworks but
there's no statutory law now supporting
those
Frameworks and and you look at
Frameworks can you find the academic
standards within or do you see something
just like this page right here with a
whole lot of words on it but not
specific academic standards I may be off
course here but you know if I was a
school principal I'd want to know what
are the academic standards for social
studies and or for
math well or or just sticking with with
the very first piece right here because
I think it's it it it applies whether
you're talking you know math or science
social studies this first section is
talking about Arts
education um and and and it's currently
it requires a program that that includes
seven
items and I don't know if these are the
seven items that should be the minimum
um comp you know the only place you're
going to cont underneath the definition
of curriculum and I wrote it when we put
it in there it says curriculum means
lessons an academic content taught in
school or in a specific course or
program
so and that was done a lot in
conjunction with CTE believe it or not
because we have courses that lead to
that program the total program as a
whole the same thing happens with the
teaching of reading in schools as
well
so I see program as as a larger
component than the individual course and
I think in the top part where we see
Arts education program is accurate what
we have now and then we get down into
the curricular instructional and
assessment stuff down below where
there's more flexibility for the
district to teach and use so so maybe Mr
chair that's that you know if if um if
we're going to take away of take take
not take away if we were going to make
changes to the
the the statutes and the associated
minimum academic standards that
providing some definition behind
program and then and then um specific
definitions to um to curriculum
instruction and assessment and each one
of those things has has you know you can
drill down into each one of those
components right I mean I don't know but
assessment you'd have competency you'd
have other assessment local
assessment you're not talk
yeah
and then you'd have the the core content
areas which which we've talked about
before Mr chair the substantive
educational content of an adequate
education in
e2a see
that page
reference has 193 c23 where where where
are you Linda page turn turn on your mic
so yeah page 547 yeah um over under
C3 3 which is the one that's you know in
in section two of this Arts
curriculum um it says the following
criteria shall be used in the
development of
program the academic standards specify
what students should know and be able to
do be clearly defined before assessment
procedures and exercises are developed
and then it goes down through um
teachers shall be involved in designing
and using assessment systems
so as you said assessment is a part of
this is it yeah is a part of the program
was part of the program yep and it it
says academic standards
specify what students should know and be
do I'm looking at initial
proposal page four it talks
about
um reer technical
education B says An approved CTE program
should be one that program
it then talks about curriculum specific
competencies um it talks about
assessments and nationally recognized
Career Cluster areas agriculture
government Hospitality Etc all
underneath the
program right not get then if you wanted
to get into um curriculum for
Hospitality that would be something
different so I I don't see any problem
here in terms of it as I think chairman
lad said program is the
umbrella you know they're using the word
program the page that uh represent
Tanner just referenced there is a
definition for
program but they talk about that
definition for the Improvement and
assessment component of this that's so
it's a it's relevant to that chapter
we're talking about and and if you were
writing this like you did the CTE
program that that on page four that
you're just doing where it talks about
you know all the things in the CTE and
you're saying that people specialized in
in business and postsecondary education
aligned with National Industry standards
Etc on the top in in our Public School
Systems it that would have been the
Frameworks where art people people who
are Professionals in art education would
get together and decide the the
necessary parts of that particular
education or music I mean to kind of jam
them all together is kind of hard cuz
music is a little bit different but um
you know here under CTE you've allowed
the different groups the nationally
recognized clear clusters the groups
within that to set out the the standards
and yet with Public Schools you've got
all this other stuff that hasn't that
isn't specific there's nobody from the
Arts you know it used to be that social
studies teachers got together um people
in SEC postsecondary whole bunch of and
they would they would make the
Frameworks and for the standards and
that's not done
know um the another U point on the
section in the initial proposal that
represent of cordelli was just
referencing under
CTE on
page page four
um the replacement of the word program
with curriculum wasn't to replace
program with curriculum but it's being
used as a as an adjective to describe
the competencies so it's it's it's
assessment that's being discussed there
so whether those competencies are
program specific competencies or
curriculum specific competencies and if
program is the combination of curriculum
instruction and assessment
then then you
know um curriculum specific competencies
would seem to
be because you're doing an assessment
independent of instruction instruction
is is what facilitates getting you
getting getting from the curriculum to
the assessment right right
yes that's the peanut butter and jelly
between the two other parts and and so
um so the assessment is to the
curriculum which would
make sense to me not being a
teacher fluffing utter yeah the fluffing
cookie well I think this element is just
confusing in everything we're going to
be looking at today yeah but I think
what representative Tanner has has
identified here is that repl not every
time program is replaced by curriculum
does it do the same thing in some cases
it's it's a clarifier in other cases it
meaning yeah they're using it two
different ways
here I feel like I'm stuck in traffic on
Route
three I'm just watching a traffic go by
the house at 10:30 11 o'clock at night
bumper bumper on Route 10 9 o' really
[Music]
yeah should have followed you Lind I got
to remind people too we have a on Route
10 going through hail corner there's a
speed
limit not not at night and that crew
last night was doing 60 70 miles hour in
a
35 we've been sitting for three hours
yeah
yeah I guess we're being recorded so I'm
not going to admit anything on the K
right well where are we on yeah where
where are we going I I think I think we
got to come up with with questions for
the department and
um there's I think goes back to the very
first thing you were saying at the top
here and by putting curriculum on top of
all these things it starts to me like
we're starting
control yeah
yeah
okay let's try to review a few things
definition of both both or both the
right so so Mr chair just some notes
that I took um you know how is program
defined talking about I like what
represent Woodcock talked about the CIA
curriculum instruction assessment um
where where program is being replaced
with the word curriculum what does that
do in in you know because I think it
does different things different places
and listed an example such as 30631
absolutely yep and then as 30 631 but
then also as we just talked about in
30633 replacing program with curriculum
is just
modifying the compet it's it's talking
about describing the competencies and
the curriculum based competencies not
program on that particular section
you're talking about 33 on page five
going down to number seven there offers
approved CTE
programs yeah they have program s with
you know with courses involved within so
we're using programs there as the
umbrella as an umbrella that has
programs underneath it yes yeah so
yeah um but then Mr chair you also
talked about is is is the state taking
on responsibility of curriculum as
opposed to
Frameworks you sort of pose that as a as
a
question
and then representative Cornell had you
know the changes from shall to May um
standards what's up you're not sitting
at bar right well I I think the shall in
May you shall provide a
program you shall provide that within
that program you get the
maze but the Statewide assessment is
going to
determine the it's going to should be
based off your academic standards for
that
program
and the competencies which follow along
where you are on those
standards so so that I think there is a
a place for
May a lot of times we put in legislation
such as or not limited to may you know
they may not have a component of this
like I mentioned on number six there on
the first page Crossing out the F use
technology as a way to create perform
and respond in various art disciplines
you may not as as part of your art
program use technology you may or music
or music
yeah that's a local but I would I would
just like to know what what they were
thinking of when they did why they did
that just and it may be okay I would
just like to to hear why okay
noted
should so so that's a that's a a good
question but I don't think there's a
requirement that every student take in
our class but there's a requirement for
every High School to provide a a program
that meets the current minimum standards
but now they have to take well you'd
have to go look at that chart on the 306
rules and see if of the 20 required C
you know credits right is there
something required in art yeah I would
venture there is for for a graduation
credit yeah yeah
[Music]
you and graduation competencies differ
from District to District so so let's
just love love you know speculating here
but so if there was let's say a a half
credit graduation requirement for art
that it could be in any of dance it
could be in dance it doesn't have to be
in art history right but it doesn't have
to be in art history
right but
but schools currently under the minimum
standards are required to provide a
program which includes each of these
seven components so so it doesn't have
to be all within the
same class for lack of a you know course
for lack of a better word but um but the
schools have to provide the opportunity
for students to take a
course that gets you these
yeah so in Manchester right now they're
required to have four credits of English
three credits of math two credits of
science two and a half credits of social
studies one credit of fizzed and one
half credit each of art computer
literacy and health along with six
electives they're increasing that in
so the so the half Credit in in art that
Manchester
requires is not necessarily going to
get a student who just takes that half
credit all of these
seven areas in there but but Manchester
has to but but a student that wants to
maybe have have four out of their six
electives also in art they're going to
be able to really extend into
this and that's where the students voice
and choice comes it and if you look at
the first word in all the top seven ones
the Sy system systematic and sequential
you have you know the words like create
perform participate analyze recognize
relate use and become familiar so those
are
the those are what would guide you as
to you know how you would teach it how
you would set up your teaching that you
okay
I'm looking on the uh at the final
proposal on page
21 uh where they're talking about High
School curriculum credits and
co-curricular
programs the local school board shall
require that the that the curriculum
content and learning opportunities
developed for each High School outlines
comp for each High School
outlines
competencies that doesn't make much
sense doesn't make much sense does it
but then it lists all these program
areas
I understand what they're trying to do
they're trying to get a competency based
education moving in the
state which I don't have any objections
to that we
shouldn't
um yeah yeah I you know like B yesterday
the the Bia he's all for this compy
based had that's what they want we had
it it was Pace pardon me we had it yeah
we had that exactly but this doesn't go
back to that
program it cuts out rigor I don't think
I don't think people can hear you when
when because so we had pace which was
which was implemented in a lot of
schools we got a waiver from the federal
government yeah and it was it was
implemented at a lot of schools and we
had a lot of professional development on
it and then all of a sudden we did away
with it so some schools are still you
know a lot of teachers really most
teachers I think agree with Competency
Based and so you know they're still
doing a part of it but uh why aren't we
going back to what the Frameworks of
out I don't know if we got the exception
from the federal government to do that
pace is an
assessment
process it's got the other two yes it
was also a national program that was
then you know it was developed in this
state yes by uh all
leather
yeah righty anything else on this so I
guess we uh send our questions forward
and then revisit I think that what we
need to do is send them right now over
to Nate green and Company m get a
response and have them come back and we
can meet again to chew on it heard me
yeah yes yes yes I think I think Dr
Green would be a really good person up
this yeah we have a little bit of time
about
yeah so just to wrap it up a little bit
here program vers curriculum we need
definition of both of those
terms um in terms of the 306 rules here
um and we want
to on page five at the bottom of numbers
and9 the uh initial
proposal it talks about
programs but you know so how we're using
program and how we're using curriculum
that's I think that's the Crux of what
we've been trying to do does curriculum
include which I don't think it does
instructional assessment but program
include curriculum the three curriculum
instruction assessment I think it should
should um and and I and I think the word
program in the old rules and in the
statute said I think program is not
always consistent on how it's beinged
and then we also represent Cornell's
issue at the top with a sh in the May
right is there anything else that's
specifically that we'd like to get some
answers
on
teach yeah I think that's see the these
this section of of rules references the
competencies back on Ed
30621 over and over and over again and
that was the the those pages I
referenced a second
ago and then you go look at the
definition of competencies I think
here yeah Linda I I think you you talked
about the definition of instruction as
well MH
instruction
teaching so uh just to follow up on Pat
um representative
Cornell's that in a couple places where
it strikes out like the local school
board shall require a family and
consumer Science Education and
instead the local school board shall
provide um
that's that's the that's the difference
you know between requiring that a family
and cons consumer science education
curriculum or program be provided and
they just cross it out and put just
provide that it's not
confusion like on the uh initial
proposal on page
15 we're talking about physical
education your Bailey work represent
Tanner and
under B I guess it's a new B it used to
be one on page
15 systematic instruction and
curriculum is that within the program or
you see we're using these
terms differently
consistent
okay the other thing consistent with the
competencies the competencies are based
off what the academic standards
where in the bar do you master or
exist question yeah you're talking about
competency standards I'm talking about
academic
standards which are the which should be
the framework for competent controlling
it all mhm
yeah you measure competencies yeah yeah
yeah that's going back to the old
Frameworks which you can't find them you
know you can't find those standards
specifically saying academic standards
Frameworks so I got the impression that
Frameworks yeah which is confusing in
yeah okay well if you can think of any
other questions let us know so I can get
this put together and get over to him
right
off but I think the best person Comer
green
anything
else do we know who actually wrote These
or pardon me do you know who actually
wrote These or no okay I have no idea
there I know there was a contracted
service but where it's been how long has
this been year and a half two
years there's been a lot of versions
since that
original yeah see here we're working off
of a version which is the
initial and the other is the
final right are we going to get a side
by side from Jen with when we when we do
the 306 is a total we will the final
with the with the when we do that legis
she's busy doing some three side byid
now individual Senate bills which are
coming in from various committees and we
have one coming down we're going to be
looking at later today which is a side
by side
for S SP
378 s378 is one that's dealing with the
performance-based school accountability
system I ask that we get a side by side
for
that we're going no but something we
need to
discuss no that one's not
scheduled but it'll be handed out so and
and then I think a final thing that
would be helpful Mr chair I'm looking
for
my
uh
oh on the
um on the
the the the two-pager that was um handed
out 20
24-42 it's the notice number academic
public schools on page two they have the
date of the deadline for submission and
right of April 30th public hearing on
April
11th that it would be good to see where
um where the
timeline would
include this committee making its
um position or recommendations whatever
you know whatever it's called and and
then the uh the statutory um uh
legislative oversight committee the 193
e committee that that you chair yeah
when when it needs to when it needs to
be I'm not looking for a specific date
but an order of operations that that um
you know the State Board had to do
something to get these rules to us these
proposed rules to us and then the ad hoc
committee is meeting has to do something
the the oversight and
accountability statutory
committee has to meet and do something
and then J and then the state board has
has to meet and do something because the
accountability the accountability and
oversight committee has to do something
before the State Board votes for
approval that's actually in statute of
of which approval of which of academic
standards of academic of which some of
these fall into that area fall into that
area even even the very first one we
were looking at here which goes from a
sh to a May provide these areas content
areas um and then and then following
that the um the the state
board can make an approval and then it
goes from there but it would be it would
be good to see that stepbystep process
and how that lines up so that we're
clear
now also we need to reference page 55
559 under
19328 where it says the minimum
standards for public school approval for
the areas identified in paragraph one
that's the substantive educational
content of an adequate
education um goes on shall constitute
the opportunity for delivery of an
adequate education the general court
shall periodically but not less than
every 10 years review revise update as
necessary the minimum standards
identified in paragraph
one so we have responsibility for
looking at everything associated with
that those content areas right
there and where they where are the
overlapping these these these standards
right here um making sure that they're
being met make sure they're and when
they're revised they're still being met
that's our responsibility and that's why
the bill was put forward where we're now
including the minimum standard of public
school
approval and I hope they're still being
applyed by
Doe
um are you know part of our oversight
responsibility rather than just academic
standards and are receiving the
authority to do that not under the
oversight committee but right there on
read yeah how can all these changes not
have any fiscal
cost I I was just looking at that fiscal
impact statement it says there's no
difference in costs when comparing
comparing the proposed rules it seems
with all those changes that's going
to take a lot of local money that's why
Nate
yeah okay we are called quits here today
I think we're just you know we're
searching but I I think we've got our
basic questions so we can get those over
the Nate have Nate respond to us come
back to this group
again and we'll go from there
great thank you
done
e
ahead
it's right
here I was just wondering how the
pronunciation
like say it again
poker 10 10 times in a row poker
poker no no no no no
quiet very good okay I'd like to welcome
everybody to the house education
committee today today we have uh several
bills which we have up for executive
session um I'd like to welcome Steve
bogert who's sitting in for Kristen
Noble welcome Steve thank you he comes
from
uh Public Works in Highway now what's
about
okay yeah that's right their job was cut
out for them
yesterday okay so what I'd like to do is
go ahead uh there are several bills
which we are not going to be discussing
today in case somebody in the public is
here to hear us talk about those bills
uh we we want to do a little bit more
work on S SP
217 and an s speed 340 340 is
communication between parents and school
school special education and 217 is Rule
and underserve educator incenter program
um we recognize the value of those bills
but there is some work we got to do and
in regard to 340 after we heard the the
audit report the other day there may be
some areas which we want to add on to
that particular bill so I'll start right
out well in a
second where did he
go right here
okay I was my laptop oh I forgot your
laptop
okay so uh before we get into specific
bills everybody should have in front of
them some amendments which were passed
out uh relative to
338 the next one would be um
374 that is a bill dealing with
licensing of part-time teachers no
there's no Amendment for that excuse me
no Amendment for
374 um going on down
441 uh that deals with the The Advisory
Group to examine potential funding
sources for Career Technical education
Capital Improvements Construction
renovation uh there is an amendment for
that
441 uh 443 we do not have an amendment
for 521 yes we do have amending language
for 521 that's educational credentials
for master
teacher and 528 the last one will be
done today Trustees of the University
system there's an amendment for 528 as
well so those amendments you should have
in your possession I'm going to hand the
gavl off to represent cordelli to
introduce SB
338 uh thank you Mr chairman uh House
Bill
338 um is next and that is relative to
the education Professional Standards
Board and I call upon chairman lad for a
motion yes I'd like to make the motion
OTP on SB
338 second by representative Miler uh
discussion yes uh I'd like to offer
Amendment 14108
that's an amendment for SB
1410 is there a second for the
Miler
um representative lad would you like to
speak yes I'll keep it brief uh we have
a Professional Standards Board in
education for uh for teachers uh this
board is comprised of 21 members and
as a member of The Advisory Council for
Career Technical education and
recognizing the value of that program
and how that is expanding and how it's
so much needed in this state uh the
amendment on line 9 of
1410 States nine members representing
classroom teachers education Specialists
or instructional Specialists that's
already in-law of which one shall be a
Career Technical education
teacher and on on line
14 there is change there as well after
we had the hearing we had this input as
well but this is phrased a little
differently on 11 uh line 11 says nine
members representing higher education
education Administration with at least
three employed by community college
system in New Hampshire member
institution education department or
university system New Hampshire member
institution education department and
with at least one employed at as a
Career Technical education principal so
by doing it this way we're inserting the
principal into the category it's dealing
with
Administration and we can keep the
number stable at 21 people on the
Professional Standards Board but we've
been able to put all that two people
recognize the importance in in CT Career
Technical education which is in all the
schools throughout 25 centers in the
state and a couple of them out outside
and Vermont but and with instructors the
talent that we see there is really
wonderful I met with the advisory
Council yesterday I see what's going on
at conquered high in their CTE
program when I see folks coming out one
young man we talked to in terms of
electrical engineering what do you get
expect to get on an hourly wage when you
graduate from high school I expect to
get around $60 per hour and with
overtime I'm guaranteed over $100 per
hour that's where we want our young
people going getting that skill and
knowledge and that's why we need to have
this on that board thank
you uh represent Miler anything I'm good
he said great thank you uh any further
comment by the
committee uh see none um Madam clerk
there there's a hand up oh I'm
sorry represent Woodcock did you have
something yeah it goes along with this
morning thank you um just the question
repres letter on the part that says a
principal uh Career Technical principal
are they are they classified as a
principal or as a director the the uh it
used to be director Steve
rothberg it's no longer he left and they
are splitting that governance apart
they're in the same building but it's
now principal she is a principal of the
CTE program and with
that she is able to do much much more
with um Workforce with manufacturing
business in in the area and she's
drawing from 13 different sending
schools as a principal she has that
credential okay but she also has a
background in business okay and so yes
we do have people that are title
principal in these centers and that's
going to grow seeing that it's
absolutely too much for where Steve was
before where he was vice principal SL
director that was it's like having the
president of a college and Provost in
one person it's too much it's the follow
up Mr M Mr chairman follow up yes the
only thank you Mr represent the only I
was thinking about the other career CTE
directors around the state this was sort
of this would sort of preclude them and
just make it just for the the conquered
one if if I read that correctly that's
all I thought the intent was open up to
that position of CTE
director Steve here might have something
that that that's it's it's already
permissible to have other directors on
that in fact I believe that they don't
have that board filled thank you
yeah do you want you're you're Chang um
yeah um Mr applebe um do you have a
us thank you Mr chair and good afternoon
everyone I apologize for dressing down
it's a little warm just come from
shoveling snow a few days ago and now
it's 80 so um the title for many years
was CT director the last time the
administrative Rule and endorsement was
updated several years ago at the request
of the CT directors it was changed in in
our um uh administrative rules to CTE
principal so all individuals who current
who held a CTE director license that the
wording was changed to principal because
the requirements to be a CTE principal
or director even before were all of the
principal requirements and then
additionally some business requirements
so they're all CT principles today
Statewide thank you thank you so much uh
thank you very much for your input uh
anything
further um Madame clerk we can vote on
the amendment I believe Vice chairman
cordelli
yes representative
beler yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative bogert yes representative
Pell yes representative Cora yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
Luna yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman
yes uh 19 y zero
n uh chairman lead do you have a further
motion yes I'd like to make the motion
that uh SB 338 be otpa with the
amendment being
second uh any discussion further no
further discussion great anything from
the
committee see nothing Madame
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative
bogert y yes representative Pell yes
representative Corell yes representative
Terry yes representative Miler yes
representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y z nay consent okay
great chairman back to you thank you
very much uh so we'll bypass 340 go down
to the next one which is
374 licing licensing of part-time
beler thank you Mr chair I would move
itl is there a
second motion made to itl by
representative beler and second by
represent Myer further discussion from
the maker thank you Mr chair I'll keep
this short uh very simply there was
certainly some um during testimony and
debate some issues brought up with the
possibility at least of a 30-hour
threshold pushing some current full-time
teachers given the the variable
schedules into a sort of weird status
possibly
part-time um so certainly our portion of
the committee would be more um more in
line with a 20-hour threshold as we have
previous ly sent to the other side of
the house or the side of the wall rather
thank you further discussion from the
second said well any further
discussion Madam clerk would you please
call the role pleas chairman
cordelli yes representative Belcher yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative
bogert yes representative Pell yes
representative Corell yes representative
Terry
yes representative Miler representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
baboni yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
n any problems with consent represent
Miler thank you uh so we are now down to
the next bill which is the able savings
account program this is SB
377 represent Dr you recognize for a
motion yes I'd like to make a motion of
a to pass is there a second we have a
motion made by representative dry uh OTP
and second by representative Miler
representa dry do you have any comments
yeah thank you um I I believe that this
solves some of the problems that they
had changing over um the plans and um
and taking care of some of the
housekeeping things it sounds like a
good thing and it's willing um deserving
of support thank you represent Miler all
set any further discussion from the
committee Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative bogert yes representative
peternell yes representative Cor yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
albon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y zero n thank you very much uh
rolling on down through here s SP
441 this is a bill Advisory Group to ex
potential funding sources for Career
Technical education parentheses CTE
construction and renovation I'm going to
pass the gavl off to represent cordelli
uh thank you Mr chairman um Senate Bill
441 uh does the chairman have a motion
yes I'd like to make the motion of OTP
for
sb441 representative Cornell second
we have an amendment and the amendment
is
amendment is there a
second yes okay thank you very much
jumped the gun there um on on this bill
this is again a CTE Bill dear to our
hearts here um when you look at the bill
as introduced on line eight of the bill
it says the Comm commer of Education or
design do period such design be may be
the state director for CTE well if you
look at the line right above it it says
the state director for CTE so you know
it's already been stated so we deleted
that part um the second part after
meeting yesterday with the CTE folks
over at conquered High uh on this
Advisory Group because we're recognizing
there is a need to move forward with
understanding how to better support the
building construction and restructuring
revision of of the um of the current uh
CTE programs throughout the state and
this is area where we're at the end of
that Loop in terms of funding the
Capital Construction about ready to
start again with the 20 plus CTE centers
and we recognize the program we have in
place is outdated not really meeting the
specific needs a program Etc so so this
group right here is being put together
for the purpose of coming forth with
recommendations back to us it does not
involve any committee members or
Representatives or Senators it's made up
of people from the field and we're
looking for them for some Pearls of
Wisdom that can help us in developing a
capital construction plan and so on the
other addition to this on that you
notice on the amendment self there's a
line eight and it puts in two
representatives of business and industry
so we can have folks from the field from
the workforce also engaged with those
folks which are identified uh on on that
amendment and the bill great represent
Cornell yes having served on the
advisory committee for quite a few years
now um the representatives on it from
business and industry are very invested
in the success of CTE program so I think
this would be a great addition to this
and I'm sorry I missed the meeting
yesterday but I couldn't get out of
Manchester to drive north on
93 in the wrong direction you could go
south uh thank you uh any further
discussion from the committee on the
amendment representative
Woodcock no okay on the amendment
anybody no
takers
um uh
we can take a vote on that represent
excuse me Madam clerk uh Vice chairman
cordelli yes representative beler yes
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative bogert yes
representative Pell yes representative
corello yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative wock
representative Hall yes representative B
bony yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y d a further motion chairman lad
yes I'd like to recommend for
s441 otpa with the amendment being uh
H thank you represent Cornell did you
want to second that
motion thank
you I have no further discussion no
further discussion uh representative
Woodcock you chairman cell represent L
Steve I was just trying to be clear
well from understanding what he just
said he probably yes
um because apparently it changed a few
years ago I missed it but I think a
number of us missed
it so my question represent cour earli
was that on line 12 it says that the
there should be three folks from C to
directors we just clarified this will be
principles I lo at or make amendment I
just
questioning right any further
questions once is the chairman going to
incorrect just you know there's a number
of ways it can be
corrected uh say yes or no
okay rather than having to write
something right now I would just prefer
to have the Senate say okay we can
request the committee of conference to
change one word and we say yeah go with
it and be done with it thank you seeing
none Madame clerk when you're ready Vice
chairman cordelli yes representative
Belcher yes representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative bogert yes representative
Pell yes representative Coro yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative heat yes
representative Woodcock absolutely
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y a consent consent great thank
you very much uh so now we're skipping
down to s443 definition of school
Transportation vehicle and I recom
recognize represent Myer for a motion
yes I would uh move the OTP and I'll
second
that represent Miler yes this uh this
bill we've seen before and in other
iterations but I believe that the uh
bill now working with the um uh safety
um Department uh has matched some of the
concerns that we had in the previous
Bill and um we commend that we OTP this
thank
you and I I have nothing further to
discuss that was well said any further
this you ready Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative beler yes representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative bogert yes representative
Pell yes representative Corell yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 19 y zero
be next bill is
521 this bill deals with educational
credentials for master teacher I Look to
represent Terry for a
motion uh thank you Mr chairman I ought
to
pass I okay we have a motion made by
representative Terry OTP and second by
representative Miler represent Terry
would you like to speak to your motion
or is there an
amendment uh I I'll speak to the motion
when it's appropriate but I understand
there's an amendment okay I will
H does everybody have a copy of
that I'll second the amendment if a
second is
needed okay thank
you um so this amendment I'll speak to
that um I I think this is uh important
that we recognize uh our our outstanding
teachers and I think in the amendment
lines one through five
encapsulate what I think it's all about
the State Board of Education shall Grant
the educational credential of Master
teacher to those persons who deserve
recognition for the extraordinary
learning opportunities they provide New
Hampshire students and will have
fulfilled at least the following
requirements and then there are specific
requirements that we have listed down
below
here
and like on on nine of the line nine
demonstrated quality teaching of the
professional education standards with
evidence of student growth and
achievement and going down looking
through uh the other criteria that are
listed here on lines 13 through uh 20 in
the
portfolio um there there is an article
item there on line 15 I think is really
important and this is oftentimes what I
see as a a professional Master Level
teacher and I been in the business for
well over 30 years in the classroom as
as an elementary principal
administrator uh High School expectation
for students ensuring that each child
develops and realizes their full
academic and social potential so you
want to have high expectations for every
kid in that class regardless of where
they're from what they are Etc Johnny
might be a real you know nut job but you
have to have high
expectations and so I think this
extremely important and the master
teacher can do this and the master
teacher also inspires other
teachers and and what you see by that is
the whole school environment improving
student performance improves pride in
the building improves and that's what we
want to see in education so I I I
appreciate the amendment being you know
21 further discussion yes represent
Woodcock thank CH this the question and
I I I do support the the bill I I was
just curious on uh item line a on the
amendment how are you going to measure
excellence and and on line 17 the the
factor
Congeniality what that has to do with
the master
teacher how you work with the others
around you collaborate on the skills and
knowledge and and performance and
development Congeniality is how you
interrelate uh personality wise um where
I found that was from a man called
William
Bennett remember who William Bennett was
Secretary of Education from man I think
1986 underneath Reagan and this is one
he wrote a book that which works and
this is one of the areas which he
indicated many of these things which are
already written here right have been
added to added to for example like on
line 14 leadership but also
supervision there's two components there
that came out of that book as well so
this is where this came
from okay thank
you further
discussion you ready Madam
clerk Vice chairman cordelli yes
representative Belcher
no representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative vurt yes
representative Pell yes representative
cortiella yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell yes representative Tanner yes
representative luno yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 18 y One
motion you got to can you come up with a
motion first please and a but too am I
didn't I already move this no I'm moving
it as a I'll I'll second that and you
you have the floor okay thank
you I believe uh when we discussed this
bill um it was acknowledged that we
don't have any Master Teachers in the
state of New Hampshire not for the lack
of qualified individuals for the
position but it was put forth I think
rather reasonably that there is a uh
substantial and perhaps prohibitive
Financial hurdle that persons uh have to
jump uh in order to be able to qualify
for uh the master teacher uh
certification so what this bill does is
it substantially lowers that and so it
makes it uh non prohibitive now for
individuals to seek to pursue this from
a financial standpoint second um we we
want to have teachers who are excellent
in their field be encouraged to uh
pursue this uh this recognition and I
think most importantly Mr chairman um
what this does is that this provides a
very real incentive uh for teachers and
um therefore uh the beneficiaries being
uh students to see um Excellence improve
in um the particular areas in which the
individual would be uh certified as a
master teacher this is I think a win-win
all the way
around thank you very much and that was
well said I have nothing further to say
on
that further discussion from the
committee not seeing any hands M
clerk than chairman Celli yes
Representative beler no representative
dry yes representative McDonald yes
representative vurt yes representative
Pell yes representative corello yes
representative Terry yes representative
Miler yes representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno yes representative Heath yes
representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative B
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 18 y One
n okay hearing exent okay thank you all
righty okay thank thank you um the last
bill we have today is Senate Bill
528 uh this is a bill relative to the
trustees the university system I will
pass the Gabel off to represent
Celli uh thank you Mr chairman and uh I
call on the chairman for a motion yes I
have the right to recommend
OTP do we have a second second second by
Regin Miler uh discussion yes thank you
very much and I'd like to offer
h u is there a second to the amendment
sure second thank you discussion
chairman lad yes
um as a trustee with the university
system right now I'm very familiar with
what's going on internally in fact we're
meeting on Friday to interview our new
and determine who will be our new
president for
UNH um however we also have a uh a a
board a group of Trustees which has
students from the various campuses as
participants as you recall when this was
introduced by Senator gray he was
recommending that there be two student
Representatives on the trustees we have
three
campuses uh we used to have four and
when Granite State was merged into UNH
that system
uh with with Manchester and law and and
the main campus uh we ended up with
three campuses Keane Plymouth and UNH
but we only have two slots available the
trustees themselves voted you
overwhelmingly to have three slots so
that for the that period of the three
years you're going to have a
representative from each of the campuses
we also have an alumnus or alumni uh
slot for Granite State
College and that person's on right now
is a very active
participant and so the way this bill is
uh uh written that parti particular slot
will cease June 30 2025 at the end of
her term on on the trustees so what this
does it instead of putting two there it
UPS it to three um I will say that the
the student trustees are very very well
engaged I'm going to be meeting with a
group in May up at Plymouth state
they're active they they're watching
what we do they're watching what the
state does in terms of education and
they're very very involved what's even
what's going on right now with the the
report that came out from the governor's
task force um where we're going in terms
of um alignment of and strategies to
make our system more efficient but still
continue to be the great system that it
is so I would urge us to consider 1425
in the positive um it would allow these
uh three positions so each campus will
have their own um uh senate or our uh
trustee representative thank you very
much oh well said by the chair great
thank you any further comment on the
amendment by the
committee see nothing oh I'm sorry
represent Woodcock chair I just question
um I understand during the testimony
they talked about the position uh of the
alumni and I see that in the amendment
you moved it to 2025 that would call
Align with the that person's uh getting
done I wonder why if it's such a
valuable position we take it
out why that why the alumni position the
institution is important and obviously
it is we're extending the date why would
we think take that person off the board
not that person but that off the board
it's a recommendation of the trustees
the total group it's
also a the campus no longer exists it's
now
doe um and I understand there are alumni
but they also now are part of the same
group that's going to be recognized with
UNH so the alumni of Granite State will
now be included within the alumni un
which has representation thank
you further questions or
comments seen none Madam clerk this
chairman cordelli yes representative
Belcher no representative dry yes
representative McDonald yes
representative bogert yes representative
peternell yes representative Coro yes
representative
Terry yes representative
Miler representative Cornell yes
representative Tanner yes representative
luno representative Heath yes
representative wock yes representative
Hall yes representative Bon yes
representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
yes 18 y one
day thank you further motion Madam Mr
chair yes I'd like to recommend otpa
second second second by representative
Miler uh discussion on the
otpa I have no further discussion okay
anyone
else see none mad clerk uh final roll
call for the day Vice chairman cordelli
yes Representative beler no
representative dry yes representative
McDonald yes representative bogert yes
representative Pell yes representa
Corell yes representative Terry yes
representative Miler yes representative
Cornell representative Tanner yes
representative Luna yes representative
Heath yes representative Woodcock yes
representative Hall yes representative
Bon yes representative cascaden yes
representative Damon yes chairman lad
n
consent okay we'll put that one that's
on consent well that takes us down
through the bills for today um we got
through that quickly I appreciate that
before everybody leaves uh we are
meeting tomorrow and you did receive a
side by side on one of those bills
that's SV
378 that's a bill relative to the
performance-based school accountability
system task force um take a look at it
and so we can come in knowing what it's
all all about um I think the side by
side if you read it carefully does
present some questions so for that we
need to focus and deal with so with that
are there any
other issues before us not seeing we're
adjourned thank you wow they're going to
be surprised at
work I cannot be here tomorrow I've
already told Glenn I needed a
replacement but I can't be here in the
morning either okay try and watch
for the thing what's the thing the thing
I don't even
know I got look at my calend the thing
here uh committee work session 378
that's what I mentioned you know the
thing the thing gotcha I gotta catch up
on all the paperwork here we're flying
through it so quickly I didn't have a
chance to get all the Amendments and
everything I need yeah everything's
successful and we didn't really thisa so
that's good okay that's great everything
to
for